was meinst du mit leute hat sie kommen
zu einem neuen video ich habe heute
maxime eine verstärkung an meiner seite
denn leute uns ist etwas aufgefallen und
zu ohren gekommen und zwar eine werbung
die richter keine übertreibung noch
beschissener als köln master ist und
weil ich die ganze sache so du hast mir
eines tages einfach so verändern so
links geschickt also dieser werbung
da ist es deutsche werbung ja also
deutsche werbung für den deutschen markt
für die deutsche version von seinem
produkt wir können der tür ins haus
fallen sagt vielleicht wie heißt es
punkte was ist es die app heißt asal
habt ihr bestimmt auch schon mal gesehen
wenn ihr fiel auf youtube unterwegs zeit
und es ist quasi so etwas wie
chatroulette nur als app also man trifft
sich mit fremden und kann chatten video
chatten wir wollen gar nicht lange drum
rumreden leute wir haben euch ich glaube
fast alle deutschen werbe clips rausgibt
wir werden jetzt stück für stück durch
gehen und wir werden uns darüber
möglicherweise lustig machen let's go
wir müssen kurz festhalten 2,25
millionen views hat das heißt wir haben
so viel geld ausgegeben für diese
spezielle werbung also man kann so
rechnen leute so für 1000 mal werbung
schalten zahlt man so 50 euro das heißt
für zwei millionen haben die einfache
aber so 110000 euro nur für diesen einen
clip ich kann schon etwas tanzen erstens
das ist doch keine deutschland also
keine abo sie redet ja die holländerin
und also aber ich kann schon etwas
tanzen er sagte ja ich bin ganz ohr
was sollte ich machen so die geräusche
haben sich die nachbarn oder wieso er zu
augen zu und hört zu hin so kannst du
schon hallo mac das klappt schon etwas
tanzen war schon etwas band sind
e-commerce karriere ich auch so ganz
natürlich unterhalten wie man so hat im
fenster nicht so hey nah ist als kugel
hier bekommst du her so ein bisschen
komisch dass wir sind hier zu sehen
das ganze ja ok gloria aus berlin kommt
wirklich aus berlin
ich kann's schon etwas tanzen bei ich
bin ganz ruhig mir dann können ja das
ist meine das ist der entwickler weisen
dafür krebs unterwegs und wie wird man
das so weiter also die normalen
dienstleister die sowas machen und
kämpfen dagegen hört man so perversen
dieses jahr braucht alle ja wir nehmen
euch alle aber vor allem auch ich fand
die situation auch so geil ich kann
schon etwas tanzen ja zeigt mal darf ich
da darf ich darf ich auch mal was los
und er so du weißt was ich meine
oh ja es geht mir so betriebsleiter der
titel ist ja auch tochter wird auf
frischer tat erwischt das ist eigentlich
ertappt das sind 100.000 euro das ist
ein sechsstelliger betrag an
werbegeldern rhein geflossen aber sie
konnten konnten nicht so gebessert
werden irgendwann einzustellen da hat
deutschland
[Musik]
kollege kollege ok kollegen links ja
linke hand sofort an einen ort wo wir
sie sehen können okay
das team hat noch und dann streichen zu
seinem bau dieser märkte schmeckt
schmeckt köstlich das kann sie ja gute
frage gute frage
er sieht auch gerade der schock in
seinem gesicht die mit ihren buden nicht
weiter für mich
1 kommentar so geil während diverser
getanzt hat achtung in dem mir gefällt
dieses tanzen endlich weiß er dieses
tanzen das meinen die menschen damit
irgend erkannte das nicht dieses ist
dass dieses tanzen von dem alle reden
[Musik]
kein einziger mensch in dieser vers
werbung kann deutsch
[Musik]
wer ist dieser kerl für den du kannst
ist sonst verkehrten der vorher können
wir auch mal ganz kurz über dieses
outfit sprechen von direkten fucking
bademantel mit high heels das macht das
für einen segen weil die reise dieser
litt alter komplett kathrin zettel
deutscher film
die app und sowas von runtergeladen
jetzt also ich hab mich so was von und
es so auch so aber deutlich beruhigt
euch falls ihr dachtet das ist schon
alles gewesen dass wir schon der ganze
schaden auf gar keinen fall es war so
ungefähr so klipp eins von fünf weiter
jetzt nächster club damen damen es ist
genug für alle da kurzanalyse ist wieder
unser playboy paul abbott
es ist eine gleiche es ist der gleiche
wert darauf undercover unterwegs weil
der wenig von den von seinen alten fans
die schon für den getanzt haben soll
wenn die erkannt werden aber es ist er
jetzt der dem dieses tanzen gefällt die
sich eine dann weiß ich sagt der
direktor
jeder weiß das also ich würde sagen so
leicht an realistische expectations ganz
ehrlich also machen uns nichts vor wenn
wir wirklich auf diese app gehen sollten
was wir natürlich nicht machen
was wird uns erwarten entweder optional
junge mädels die sagen hey warum bist du
so häufig oder option b alte säcke also
nachdenken
juni startet einfach die region komplett
job interview alle tag mein name ist ja
ich komme aus erfurt man interessen sind
kochen ich bin ein gutes team sportlerin
und er denkt zurzeit mit distanz
dieses tanzen damit man den ganzen tag
[Gelächter]
ja also man merkt sie wollen so ein
gewisses bild vermitteln dass auf dieser
plattform einfach viele verzweifelte
junge mädels sind mehr oder weniger
attraktiv die einfach männer wollen ja
und warum es wieder geht mein ganzes
denken schaut mal oben rechts 1800
diamanten wahrscheinlich muss man wieder
irgendwas in game währung zahlen damit
man zu den nächsten damen damen vision
kann extrahiert wer sind all diese
mädchen okay
also exakt dasselbe bild ist richtet
sich wieder irgendwelche jungen jungs
die die kreditkarte ihre eltern clown
sollen weil sie hoffen dass sie da
mädels kennen lernen sagt okay leute es
geht weiter jetzt wird's jetzt so
richtig keiner dieser clip hat 4,8
millionen aufrufe und natürlich eine
runde applaus
es ist vielleicht entdeckt der hat schon
so viel ja was für ein krieg ist diese
frau alter geht dir mal dieses diese
freiheit die augen gucken so in deine
seele also echte die frau ist so
geistesgestört diese frau ist wirklich
nicht normal also irgendwas bei der
schief gelaufen weißt du was die
wenigsten wissen weshalb die so
gestaltet ist dass sich zu oft ruppigen
1 hatte die wirkt auf mich so als würde
jemand hinter der kamera stehen und so
eine waffe auf die rechten wir sagen
jetzt sagt das jetzt und ich kenne dich
ab mit mehr über diese frau reden was
ist das für ein verhalten und metro
gegeben um das jetzt ist was redet ja
auch kein freund grob versuch wenigstens
zeug zu reden ich hasse gleich aus ich
habe ja aber keine freunde ich bin
barack obama dessen berger also kein
wunder dass das ist ja mal fragen kein
bock auf meiner dolberg also leute sagen
berichtet an der stelle hier hatte man
in der kommentar section so eine offene
beratungsstelle für geschädigte ein was
zur hölle ist eurer meinung nach mit
diesen werbungen auf sich hat irgend
erklärung dafür
lasst uns darüber gerne in den
kommentaren diskutieren max atrium in
einem schrank für den gibt's einfach ich
persönlich vorgeschlagen das video hier
können
abonieren wird das wieder gefallen hat
wir sind zu weit raus mit geschädigten
grüßen bis zum nächsten mal
schlüsse raum ganz gut